like many others being actor is forced
to search for alternatives to cooking
meals because of the increasing shortage
of gas
yes
most of the time there is hardly any gas
available in the line i work in the
garments factory so i am not always at
home it's not possible to cook with
firewood all the time
despite the frequent disruptions
customers are still having to pay for
the gas connection
it's very hard see we can't cook now
there's been no gas since this morning
it's only available late at night it's
not possible to get up at that time to
cook so we use cylinder gas when needed
how can we manage like this as
low-income people
experts say bangladesh's fast-growing
economy is facing a severe gas shortage
this year that's due to the slow pace of
exploration for new deposits of natural
gas as well as increasing dependency on
imports
amid growing domestic demand and the
jump in liquid natural gas spot prices
in the global market has come as a shock
to bangladesh as around 25 percent of
the total gas supply requirement in the
country relies on imported bottled gas
the government has ordered filling
station to close for four hours a day
because of the shortage
and textile factory owners say the
supply shortage cost the industry close
to two billion dollars in the past three
months
this has resulted
some factories with captive power which
we are running with
gas run generator
we couldn't run that
and also washing plants
were almost working 25 75 it wouldn't
work
so this has resulted a big disruption in
the production
the consumer watchdog says a short-term
solution to resolve the crisis is
urgently needed
we could temporarily suspend supplying
gas to non-essential sectors however
it's important to keep the supply intake
for industries and domestic consumers
and we should extract the gas reserves
that are already discovered and supply
those to the grid
energy experts warn that if a solution
isn't found both industrial production
and millions of domestic users
particularly low-income families will
continue to suffer tanvir chowdhury
al-jazeera dhaka